à
[Applaudissements]
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de la mousse de la peinture de l'eau et
beaucoup beaucoup de poudre
les enfants s'amusent autant que les
parents durant au lit personne n'y
échappe
tout y passe même les vaches et les
policiers les cibles privilégiées sont
les touristes et le fado à léonie mani
playbook est relié à sa manière les
couleurs sont très importantes dans la
culture 1 2 chaque pigments à sa
signification
le rouge la vie le vers l'harmonie le
bleu la vitalité et le jaune la fois
[Applaudissements]
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
venues de partout en inde se pressent
dans les ruelles étroites de vrilles
d'aval en direction du temple principal
hu a fait se passe dans un joyeux chaos
autant vous dire que je n'ai pas
retrouvé mes deux chaussures à
l'intérieur la foule se masse devant ils
cèdent une statue de la divinité krishna
cacher derrière des rideaux est enfin
dévoilé
mais seulement pour les yeux pointés la
caméra dans cette direction est
interdite krishna est un des dieux les
plus vénérés en inde
c'est ici avril davanne qui l'aurait
grandi la légende raconte qu'il était
jaloux de la blancheur de peau de son
amante rada alors il lui couvraient le
visage de couleurs l'inde est une
mosaïque de religion de casques de
classe sociale de langue de table de pot
en temps normal comme dans un arc en
ciel toutes ces couleurs cohabitent sans
se mélanger
meoli fait exception les clivages
disparaissent le temps d'une fête dans
un nuage de poudre
même si tout le monde est bien conscient
que ce rêve en couleurs
c'est de la poudre aux yeux
[Musique]